foreign
lost for words friends of 17 year old
Madi Ladue remember your young man Gone
Too Soon
Israeli forces killed Maddie with a
bullet to the chest late on Friday that
was after confrontations in his hometown
of
between Palestinians and Israeli
soldiers when locals said they were
trying to fend off an attack by Israeli
settlers a loyal and compassionate
friend is how his neighbor Adam ladada
remembers Mahdi minutes after he was
laid to rest
he used to dream of having a good future
he is someone who loved life and going
out he has gone way too soon
Palestinians say not only is there no
accountability for these killings but
the violence against them is being used
as an electoral tactic
ahead of elections in November
Palestinians say Israeli politicians
hope to get more votes by increasing
assaults on them
an attack by Israeli settlers is one of
three Palestinian teens killed by
Israeli forces in less than 24 hours in
what is turning into the most violent
year in the West Bank since 2015. out of
the 114 Palestinians killed by Israeli
forces in the West Bank this year a
third were shot in Janine in the
northern West Bank
early on Saturday two Palestinians were
killed during confrontations after an
Israeli raid in the genuine Refugee
campaign
the injuries were focused in the upper
body parts one of them was a direct
Bullet To The Head and the other was to
the neck the two men arrived at the
hospital and their hearts stopped we
couldn't resuscitate them
night and daily reads have recently been
met with armed confrontations in the
place Israel calls the wasps nests
military analysts estimate there are
hundreds of armed Palestinians inside
the Janine refugee camp last week the
Israeli military approved the use of
drones for targeted assassinations as
Palestinians use of gunfire increases
largely unarmed in the face of a violent
military occupation Palestinians say
they can only rely on themselves recent
polls suggest the Palestinian support
for an armed Uprising against Israel at
48 percent
the odds of achieving peace are low but
standing still the young hearsay is no
longer an option
the occupied West Bank